here are the top 10 most shocking and
sometimes downright jaw-dropping moments
in Hogwarts Legacy and obviously I think
it goes without saying but major story
spoilers are coming up at number 10 we
have to start with our buddy George
osrick and one of the most shocking
moments that came only minutes into the
game in the lead up to Hogwarts Legacy
we were led to believe that ostrich was
going to be an important Ministry
official chandlerwood and the marketing
team they had to be in on this they even
featured him in a dedicated social media
post with a character card and more
information about him so during the
game's opening sequence we meet osrick
and he joins the main character along
with Professor fig in a flying Carriage
within minutes of the carriage taking
flight though it's attacked by a dragon
and osric unable to operate away in time
gets well devoured by the massive winged
beast and if you're wondering if maybe
there's still some small chance that
osrick may have survived the game pretty
much confirms his death with the reveal
of thestrals which our main character
was not able to see before this moment
this certainly set the tone early that
Hogwarts Legacy was not afraid to take
out characters and potentially gruesome
fashion moving on to number nine quests
with Sebastian sallow are by far some of
the most riveting moments in the game
one of these quests has our main
character in search of Slytherin
scriptorium of course longtime fans know
Slytherin was also the founder behind
the Chamber of Secrets and the Basilisk
inside simply the mention of another
hidden room left behind by hogwarts's
most controversial founder was enough of
a surprise on its own but then we
actually get to go there the journey is
a dark and tragic one as ominous gaunt
learns the fate of his aunt naktua and
how she died before ever locating the
scriptorium and it's all because she was
traveling alone you see to get inside
the scriptorium you needed to cast
crucio on someone else and nottua was
traveling alone it's here the player
must make the choice on whether they
will cast the curse on Sebastian or have
him cast it upon them no matter which
option you choose though you eventually
do make your way into the scriptorium
left behind by Salazar Slytherin and
that leads us right into number eight
because the whole reason set continues
with his quest at all is with the goal
of saving his sister and only he
believes she was cursed by goblins this
fuels seb's hatred and disdain for the
creatures and he makes numerous comments
throughout the game about it near the
end of the game though we learn it
wasn't the Goblins who cursed Anne but
Victor Rookwood a dark wizard who had
partnered with the goblins to get closer
to the ancient magic and oddly enough
the ancient magic that his ancestor
Charles Brookwood was trying to protect
for number seven we come to Fire and
vice which was a mission in Hogwarts
Legacy that featured poppy sweding our
Hufflepuff companion it's also a mission
that was featured prominently in early
preview footage of the game and even
looking back at it now it's still one of
the most surprising moments for me in
the whole game things start off simply
enough with poppy and our main character
looking to understand more about the
mysterious horntail Hall which seems to
be at the center of the poaching
operation happening about the Scottish
Highlands we take out a few poachers as
we investigate Clues left behind and it
seems like a pretty standard Mission
until you reach this tent in a moment
that had to be inspired at least in part
by the Weasley family tint from fire we
enter to find it is not a normal tint at
all and there was actually a massive
dragon fighting ring inside the next
area can be completed with stealth but
everything ultimately ends with an epic
battle featuring Wizards goblins and
even an animagus inside the actual
Dragon Ring the battle concludes with
poppy and the main character freeing the
dragon at number six we come to the fate
of isidora morganock while Sebastian's
story is by far the most tragic in the
game the tale of Isidore morganock is a
close second through a series of pensive
memories we learn more about isadora's
connection to ancient magic and how she
used it to remove pain from loved ones
starting with her father who never seems
to recover after the death of his son
who was also isadora's brother the
memory show isadora's failed attempts at
convincing the other Hogwarts professors
that taking away the pain is something
they should be using the ancient magic
for her story ultimately leads to an
area underneath Hogwarts where she's
been storing the energy and even using
her abilities on students to remove
their pain shocked at this the other
professors confront Isadora and this
results in a crazy battle she attacks
Andrews Fitzgerald Harold but then this
happens
number five we come to Polyjuice black
in the lead up to Hogwarts Legacy mini
fans were hoping we'd have an
opportunity to see the school Under the
direction of one Phineas nigellous black
we knew it would provide a nice contrast
to Dumbledore what we didn't expect
though is that we'd actually get a
moment to play as black well through
Paula juice anyway as you and Professor
fig continue to investigate the ancient
magic connected to the school there
comes a time when you need to get inside
the headmaster's office to access the
trial of former headmistress Neve
Fitzgerald but first we'll need the
password fig comes up with a plan to ask
scrope Black's house elf for the
password but scrope will need to believe
he's actually telling black himself
otherwise he would never give it up Vic
just so happens to have some poly juice
for black as he had anticipated possibly
needing it for a moment such as this the
player then becomes black and gets to
walk through the halls of Hogwarts as
the Headmaster along the way we have
several humorous interactions with both
students and staff with some of them
even being miscible if you don't choose
to interact with the students what
happens after this Quest though is
arguably even more shocking so be on the
lookout for that here in just a moment
at number four though we have another
pretty crazy reveal that actually
happened in a side quest and not even in
one of the main missions for the game so
in the tale of Roland Oaks questline
you'll come across some pretty
significant information regarding
ranrock the main antagonist of the game
if you ever wonder what exactly made
Rand despise wizard kind so harshly
you'll find your answer here turns out
ranrock once stumbled upon an illegal
Dragon camp and became fascinated with
the creatures he'd been trying to work
up the courage to speak to the wizard in
charge when he saw an opportune moment
or at least what he thought was an
opportune moment you see the wizard in
charge had dropped his wand so ran Rock
picks it up with plans to return it to
the wizard maybe use it as an
opportunity to introduce himself this
backfired incredibly though because the
wizard saw the goblin with a wand and it
actually sent him into a rage he ended
up beating Rand Rock within an inch of
his life and from that moment ranrock
would forever despise wizard kind number
three visiting Azkaban Hogwarts Legacy
featured so many iconic spells locations
and creatures in the game but noticeably
absent was Azkaban the Patronus charm
and the Dementors well unless you played
as a Hufflepuff one Quest that all
players will get throughout their
journey in the game is the jackdaw quest
line what's different is how you get and
start this Quest and it's all based on
which house you're playing as Hufflepuff
gets arguably the most interesting start
to the quest in the game as it involves
you going to ask a man with former auror
Helen thistlewood the purpose of the
visit to speak with Anne a prisoner
there who was wrongfully accused of
jackdall's murder now don't be too
jealous if you were playing as a
different house the quest itself is
pretty short there's really not a lot of
space to even walk around in the area
and you cannot cast any spells either I
suppose you do get a look at the
Dementors which seems to be the only
place in the game to see them despite
the fact they were included in trailers
leading up to the game and even appear
on the cover art for the deluxe version
all right remember how I tease something
that happens after you Paula juice
Headmaster black we are now here at
number two and that is where we get this
reveal so once you finally reach the
headmaster's office you'll now be able
to access former headmistress knee
Fitzgerald's trial which fans often
refer to as the Deathly Hallows Mission
honestly after just completing my second
playthrough I can pretty confidently say
this is my favorite quest in the game
and certainly makes the fourth trial
after it a bit of a letdown so you'll go
into the headmaster's office you'll
interact with this book and then you're
sucked inside the book and everything
about the game shifts into a black and
white stylized world where massive
creatures representing death are gonna
hunt you throughout you'll need to use
stealth to navigate around them and
eventually retrieve the cloak of
invisibility after that you'll soon find
the Elder Wand and then you come to a
section where you need to put it to good
use in an epic battle multiple waves of
creatures all from this mysterious
Shadow realm and yes you can definitely
feel that your spells are hitting much
harder and finally after the combat
section you'll pick up the resurrection
Stone which then lets you talk with
former headmistress Fitzgerald you won't
keep any of the items after the quest as
it was only a memory I mean honestly I'm
not sure how exactly the lore works here
if Fitzgerald like hold all the Deathly
Hallows at some point what exactly was
her connection to them and why were they
featured so prominently in this trial
regardless the mission itself is awesome
and a great nod to long time fans of the
series honestly I almost put this at
number one it was really tough decided
between the two but ultimately for
number one I had to go with a moment
involving you guessed it Sebastian
sallow for me the single most shocking
moment in all of Hogwarts Legacy has to
be the moment that Sebastian Salo casts
Avada Kedavra on his uncle Solomon
sallow
must stop
I won't let her suffer
[Music]
even with all of the tension that had
been building in the lead up to this
moment and seb's Relentless quest to
cure Anne I still never expected him to
actually take the life of his uncle and
with an unforgivable curse this happens
no matter the choices you make
throughout the game although you will
have a significant say on what happens
to Seb after this moment not only is it
one of the most shocking moments though
it's also one of the most tragic if you
want to hear me break down seb's tragic
tale and the moments leading up to it in
even greater detail check out the video
on the right side of your screen now as
always thank you all so much for
watching I'll talk to you again soon